han sido muy breves las palabras de
Álvaro oliva esperábamos quizás que nos
hubiera dado un par de datos más algún
dato más porque no ha trascendido
demasiado de lo que ha pasado durante
esta Cumbre Quizás lo más llamativo ha
sido las palabras de Joseph el jefe de
la diplomacia europea diciendo que ellos
y que están abiertos a abrir algunas de
las sanciones no sé si usted tiene más
información pero qué balance se podría
hacer de esta cumbre en la que
recordemos finalmente no han estado in
situ ni las delegaciones del gobierno ni
de la oposición venezolana
fundamentalmente lo primero que hay que
decir es que en el derecho internacional
público Respecto a los Estados lo más
importante es la voluntad de las partes
y hay que plantear que este es un primer
acercamiento por parte de los países que
tienen alguna intencionalidad de que se
resuelvan estas situaciones planteadas
por parte de el canciller colombiano
dentro de Venezuela las sanciones y el
proceso democratización sin embargo esto
no va a tener un gran alcance hasta
tanto no haya un reconocimiento por
parte del gobierno Nicolás Maduro de su
intencionalidad de abrir las
posibilidades de un proceso
democratización y por otro lado de
países como Estados Unidos quienes
tienen las sanciones más fuertes contra
Venezuela a nivel económico de Islas
reduciendo paulatinamente
hoy lo que tenemos Tal vez es un avance
respecto a la posibilidad de que se
discuta desde la región latinoamericana
en donde se albergan 5 millones y medio
venezolanos de los 7 millones de
migrantes que hay a nivel mundial para
que se pueda empezar a hablar de la
posibilidad desde la región de Buscar
también soluciones sobre esta crisis
alrededor de las sanciones
específicamente con relación a la Unión
Europea es muy gratificante ver que haya
también una voluntad de que se hable de
la posibilidad en conjunto de reducir
estas sanciones sin embargo hay que
esclarecer también que existe una
diferencia muy grande entre las
sanciones al país es decir a Venezuela
de carácter económico sobre el bloqueo y
las sanciones que están relacionadas con
Los Altos funcionarios del gobierno
venezolano del partido del psuv incluido
el propio presidente Nicolás maduro y
este tipo de sanciones las últimas sobre
las personas tal vez son las que van a
hacer en un proceso de negociación
muchísimo más complejo con países como
Estados Unidos en cuanto a las sanciones
respecto a el país a Venezuela el
bloqueo económico Es evidente que
también aquí hay un dilema respecto de
Qué se debe hacer primero si se levantan
las sanciones económicas que llegan
alrededor a los veinticuatro mil treinta
mil millones de dólares para que haya un
proceso democratización con recursos
públicos o se empieza a hacer un proceso
democratización a la parte que se
reducen las sanciones económicas este es
realmente el punto crucial y es algo
dentro de lo cual por lo menos desde la
región ya se empezó a discutir por fuera
de un aislacionismo de Venezuela y de
salidas que en el pasado no dieron
ningún resultado bueno habíamos
escuchado anteriormente en el día
Gustavo Petro precisamente hablar de la
región en sí como una región libre de
sanciones no solo de Venezuela le quería
preguntar por algo que ha mencionado
usted también y es el caso de Estados
Unidos claramente es uno de los actores
más importantes en todo este proceso la
falta quizás de acuerdos en esa visita
de Gustavo Petro a Joe biden ha sido en
cierto modo un fracaso del gobierno de
Colombia respecto a este proceso quizás
de negociación entre el gobierno y la y
la oposición en Venezuela
yo no lo vería como un fracaso empezando
porque el presidente Gustavo Petro creo
que no funge como un Vocero de Nicolás
maduro en ninguna instancia porque eso
violaría en principio la soberanía la
autonomía y la propia representación que
tendría Venezuela de sus propios
intereses yo creo que más bien lo que
fue tal vez desde el entendimiento de la
política internacional por parte del
presidente Gustavo Petro esta reunión en
la que se tocó el tema de Venezuela fue
para salvaguardar los propios intereses
recordemos que hoy gran parte de los
migrantes que hacen presencia en el
mundo de Venezuela están en Colombia
alrededor de uno punto ocho millones de
los siete millones de migrantes que
están en el mundo están en el país eso
genera una crisis que
se resiente por la ausencia de
soluciones en Venezuela dos están
hablándose dentro de los procesos de
negociación de la paz total con el eln
que tienen parte de su presencia
binacional
en lo que es esta frontera territorial
que compartimos en ese sentido yo creo
que la ausencia de acuerdos en relación
con el tema de Venezuela que es una
agenda que era más de carácter
confidencial fue más bien un tema de una
ausencia de entendimiento respecto de lo
que es la agenda internacional incluso
de Estados Unidos hoy vemos que Estados
Unidos va a entrar en una dinámica de
una campaña electoral para la
presidencia el presidente Joe biden hoy
lanzó su candidatura para lanzarse
nuevamente en la reelección Y eso
implica que para los intereses de los
propios Estados Unidos es más fácil
incluso llegar a discutir la eliminación
de sanciones de Rusia que de Venezuela
porque Venezuela no representa tal vez
una amenaza tan grande a nivel
geopolítico como lo representa Rusia y
esto puede empezar a entorpecer tal vez
lo que es una dinámica electoral
respecto de la narrativa de los Estados
Unidos y también lo que sería una
discusión a nivel regional Lo que sí es
cierto es que el presidente Gustavo
Petro tuvo un acierto en la posibilidad
de que se enviara una comisión por parte
de los Estados Unidos con presencia del
embajador palmeiri acá a la Cumbre de
los 19 países para que por lo menos se
escuche y se evalúe la posibilidad de
reducir estas sanciones no lo entendería
yo como un fracaso toda vez que esta
reunión que hubo por parte del
presidente Gustavo Petro con Joe biden
Tuvo una agenda mucho más amplia y el
tema de Venezuela si bien es de carácter
importante se debe centrar sobre los
intereses de Colombia que es seguramente
una de las grandes preocupaciones que
tiene el presidente Gustavo Petro para
sacar adelante la política migratoria la
restauración respecto de la frontera y
también la paz total en las
negociaciones con el eln